we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p this is a
serious question okay is this accent for
real or is this a satirical accent in
this voicemail take a listen david
pakman get a life and get a real job
could you suck it what'd you do I
honestly don't know I mean I I know that
that is an accent that is real but it
also if someone is more familiar with
the nuances of these accents I I could
be convinced that that is satirical yeah
I think all the one syllable words in
that voicemail became to solar yeah uh
remember when in in school you would be
told in order to figure out how many
syllables a word has you put your hand
below your chin and every time your chin
hits your hand that is a syllable he has
turned some single syllable words into
ones that would hit your hand with your
chin two or even three times I would say
and that goes along with the Southern
drawl a lot of the times but you know
sometimes it can be can be pleasing in
this case maybe not so much I actually
met um there when I go to this
conference in Las Vegas organized by
Mike Papantonio of Florida law firm
Levin Papantonio also bring a fire fame
there in Pensacola which as a lot of my
friends from there tell me it's
technically Florida but it's basically
Alabama it's in the Panhandle and it's
very very conservative and right wing uh
you meet people who have what is
unmistakeably a thick southern accent
but they don't in any way communicate
that stereotypical this person doesn't
sound smart thing which has really
explained to me over time because we
don't meet that many people up in this
part of the country with with that
accent that very often the portrayal of
the southern accent is a very particular
i'm guessing less educated in and maybe
lower economic class southern accent
because when you meet people like from
the Levin Papantonio law firm they've
all got a southern accent you wouldn't
think any of them are lacking a full
deck so to speak and that association
really is unfortunate and is why people
with the Southern drawl try to get rid
of it in some cases yeah but yeah I mean
it's Florida the more north you go the
more so
to get Cubs have won the World Series we
will talk about it on today's bonus show
i also want to dig in a little bit into
this idea of the shy trump supporters
that the polls are all wrong because
Trump supporters aren't even willing to
tell upholster on the phone who they're
actually voting for and will also follow
up I received a lot of comments about
yesterday's conversation about family
religion and politics all of these
stories and more on the bonus show david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 to get the
2017 david pakman show comic book
calendar free with a yearly membership